des caractéristiques du tout la
politique qui a mené qui a mené jean
michel blanquer
depuis le début de la pandémie c'est à
dire quoi les annonces ont été faites
tardivement on est dans la préparation
la plus totale il ya une égalité de
traitement énorme entre les élèves aussi
bien aux collèges qu'en lycées liés à la
mise à distance partiale des élèves qui
est très variable selon les
établissements et il a vraiment fallu
batailler pour que tout ceci soit pris
en compte et à l'heure qu'il est il ya
encore un grand nombre de problèmes qui
ne sont pas réglés mais donc ce qu'on a
demandé dans la mesure où certaines il a
été décidé que certaines épreuves se
tient quand même qu'il y ait un maximum
de cadres nationale qu'ils soient
maintenues mais aussi des protocoles
sanitaires strictes qu'ils soient mises
en oeuvre et à l'heure qu'il est on là
aussi assez plus d'informations sur ces
sur ces protocoles
ah bah oui ça certainement une année qui
a été tronquée et qui a été tronquée par
la pandémie avec une mise en place de la
réforme qu'il fallait mettre en place
coûte que coûte alors qu'on était
vraiment dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
donc oui évidemment les élèves sont
pénalisées aussi parce que il a fallu
voilà à mettre en oeuvre à toute force
une réforme avec ce grand oral qui est
de plus en plus d'appareils comme un
totem qu'on veut maintenir parce qu'il
symbolise la réforme sans aucune prise
en compte de ce qu'a été cette année
scolaire et l'année scolaire précédente